here's the problem and kids grow up and
they look back on their childhood and
all those women clapping on this crazy
lady are not gonna have to deal with the
consequences of your kids hating you
because you're partying instead of being
a mother your kids resenting you because
you weren't doing the right thing you
weren't home raising them and feminists
will parade this stuff on they'll clap
their hands they'll say all the stuff
that sound that sounds nice while they
on me for being honest
um and telling you you can't do it all
one day they figure out that their mom
was a selfish woman that would rather
put her kid in daycare and have a
stranger raise it rather than do it
herself because she wanted to have it
all she wanted to have the social life
she wanted to have the work life she
wanted to do everything and do you know
who gets the short end of the stick in
all of these situations it's children